that kind of a pink one pink one what
are you a girl what do you uh
lady makes a great color man who are you
trying to justify this to I'm trying to
tell all the alpha males watching this
beginning part no one watches us pink is
a man it's a lie it's all dead
hello and welcome to this episode of
trash taste I'm your host for today gone
and once again joining me are the boys
right now
[Music]
is pink a manly color I guess we're
starting on that [__] topic uh why
why why why is this the chance this is
the eye generated
yes is the answer yes hello hello AI
generation yes answer and I will tell
you exactly why that is I'm Googling
best podcast topics right now let's see
what comes up best podcast topics we
should we should do we we should do an
episode where it's completely AI
generated actually because I was I was
actually having a play with a chat GPT
the other day yeah uh which is like the
newest kind of like AI opens I don't
know if it's open source but it's like
available to the public right yeah um
and it's basically by open AI which is a
company that was founded by Elon Musk so
you know you know
the real-life Batman villain Elon Musk
it is scarily good it was it is actually
kind of terrifying and well you know
when I when you say that I think back to
it and I think about all the videos I've
watched where a Skyrim NPC Behavior I
think are we really that hard to emulate
I don't think we're that hard to emulate
we're pretty [__] yourself it's a
high IQ person yeah life is I I mean
like as a record is it hard to seem
somewhat human if you you know feed it
enough books and [__] well well I mean
isn't that the whole point of like the
touring test yeah yeah like well I mean
we're all like also by the way I would
like to talk about kids programming as
well I completely unrelated to my Google
search wait what that was one of the
recommended topics for a podcast kids
programming kids programs obviously the
absolute State the absolute [__]
state of kids programs please indulge Us
in what I'm sorry the state of kids I
don't watch YouTube kids actually thank
you very much I get pissed off on
YouTube and it tells me as a kid so I'm
like this is clearly not for kids
myself hold on pause was that really the
top oh that was one of them yeah so
here's what they recommended talking no
I I know the top podcaster q a is
fortnite actually overrated
topic ideas uh uh q a so we should do
that questions and answers ask me a
question yeah okay I'll ask you a
question sure our entire podcast is a
question okay isn't that paranormal do
you have good questions no we've done
we've done paranormal we've done
paranormal True Crime we spoke about
that yeah personal finance I'm not good
at it
what a riveting topic
we should do this one guided meditations
I think we should do that what do you
mean like we should guide the viewers
how to meditate do you meditate [__] no
I don't have to be a a singer to judge
singing right I was probably the only
person here that has actually meditated
yeah it's not that hard
um
kids programming time specific and
finally event planning event planning
event planning that sounds like a job
event planning guys I love I heck in
love planning events I just I just want
to plan events like birthday parties I
feel like that list was held together by
someone who's never done or watched a
podcast again so that was probably
written by a human being it was probably
written by Ai and like the AI would
probably make more interesting AI topics
right probably yeah so is it really that
hard to emulate human beings I don't
know I guess we'll test it out future
yeah I guess we'll test out on a future
episode but no like I was playing around
with chat GPT yeah um and like I think
the people I you know because our entire
[__] uh lives are now run by AI
simply because I you know started
looking into chap gbt now my entire
recommended on YouTube is all cha GPT
just because that's what YouTube thinks
that our AI is
yeah and it's actually like terrifying
for
I think program is right now software
Engineers like the amount like charge
EPT as a resource not just like it's
it's kind of like an all-encompassing a
AI you can ask it like scarily uh
scarily like human questions and it will
like literally type out an entire essay
it can do your homework for you yeah if
if you are if you if you type out like
the right prompts and everything like
that I tested it out
and I I typed in Tyler can you write a
gig Up Style review of Full Metal
Alchemist right and uh that that is that
is around 10 minutes long right right
and at first the first iteration it
types it out and it's like a kind of
like generic review and then I was like
oh try adding like a few jokes here and
there try referring to this try
referring to that it's it's
actually [__] freaked me out right
because it started adding jokes you know
like if you're familiar with my content
sometimes I do like little skits where
like some guy shouts in the background
and stuff like that chargpt added that
to the script I was like what the actual
[__] this is my my job is done my job is
actually done like it's this if if an AI
can like take my style of videos and
emulate it in the most basic sense now
What's it gonna be like [__] five ten
years in the future I uh yeah because I
I also I also did the same thing I think
the video should be out by it now but
like I decided to do a [__] post video
on my second Channel where I did a
chainsaw man anime review but the entire
script is written by AI yeah but like I
didn't use the one you used I used a
couple of the other like kind of free to
use um opens I guess they're open source
the amount of stuff I've seen online I
was like this this gotta be free yeah a
lot of them though you have to pay like
a monthly subscription to use like a
limit what the [__] using AI that much I
don't know but like the ones that I
chose uh to use while like kind of made
like the first like you know a couple of
thousand words were like yeah uses like
a test kind of thing and then if you
wanted to use like unlimited words for
however long it's like five dollars a
month or something like that and I'm
like first of all I'm not paying for a
subscription service for an AI like [__]
that so I just like use the limit for
the free to use to just be like uh just
yeah all I did was just like chainsaw
man anime review yeah and then put in a
couple of like character things and like
yeah they clearly didn't know what
chainsaw man was I thought it was a man
who was a change yeah because because he
tried to write like a like a synopsis
for it and it was like uh Jeff is a man
who owns a chainsaw shop uh and he comes
home one day to kill his wife and he
becomes the chainsaw man but I just
become okay but I just but I was like I
thought that was really funny so I just
completely left it as in and then I just
read the script verbatim yeah in like my
style
um I don't know how it's turned out
because it hasn't come out as this video
comes out but it was really funny
because like man I thought I was like
contrarian and on anime yeah this AI had
no chill it was just like it was just
like yes uh the animation was a kind of
subpar but the fighting scenes were kind
of good but overall the story was very
forgettable when Bland I was like damn
hey I chill oh my God you should give
Chad GPT a try because it's it's got it
it like writes things to a point where
you could literally take this
um like if we had Chad gbt when I was in
high school I was never doing any
[__] hurt I would not be doing any
[__] homework it's yeah it literally
gets to a point where you could ask it
to write you know you could literally
say write a python script that does this
and this and like it understands what
your request is
entire codes that's scary of like you
know like C plus plus programming python
whatever the [__] you want or you can
ask it to write you a video script about
X or Y yeah yeah you can like ask it to
iterate upon itself to be like okay take
this script and add a little bit of
humor add a little bit of this maybe
expand on this section and it's it's
[__] it's it's an amazing amazing
resources a resource but at the same
time it's [__] terrifying teachers
and professors must be [__] sweating
now because you remember like I'm
[__] sweating because because like
remember like when we were in college
and like high school and stuff like yeah
a lot like the biggest thing we had to
worry about was like don't take
citations from Wikipedia yeah like but
now it's just like don't get a [__]
super you know like hard-working AI to
basically do your workflow because like
how do you there must be measures
nowadays right because like this thing
is so openly available to like students
now and it's like a lot more well known
it's probably only going to be all well
known from here on out it's like how are
they going to figure out a way to like
make sure you're not just using this AI
right like they they probably have to I
got it I got it right you build an AI to
detect the AI
That's the only way I can like imagine
currently how they do it yeah
folks that's how they distinguished
we use the AI to kill the AI
it's just it's just modern day weapons
yeah when you make a when you make a
tank that can withstand bullets then you
add Rockets
we're gonna make us stronger it's just
always going to be this cat of mouse
game holy [__] which one is funny yeah
but but like what's what's incredible to
me is like you know when in school we
learn about like you know history and
like you know the Industrial Revolution
and how all like the workers kind of
like revolted and like protested when
you know they were getting replaced by
machines yeah and you know you you sit
there as a kid being like ah dumb
history that'll never happen and we're
literally like seeing it happen right
[__] now yeah it's actually insane
well the more that we become like NPCs
the more the NPCs become like humans
right have you not noticed the explosion
of MPC humor online have you noticed I
have noticed that yes
I've not noticed an explosion of NPC
humor it's something that's just existed
since it's show big history online
Skyrim right yeah surely but it's like
more so like people behaving like NPCs
and like Tick Tock just made it like
explode because it's so much so easy to
get like it's just America right well
yeah pretty much all of America right
like that's just clearly right we're
generalizing the entire America right
that's how it is yeah we can go back to
that it's interesting it's interesting
yeah it's that whole thing of like the
we live in a simulation meme just kind
of coming back right yeah I've seen the
simulation is failing right now yeah
I've seen I've seen so many memes like
that just like on Meme pages and like
Tick Tock and stuff like that of like oh
we I was like no we don't live in a
simulation and it's like oh really have
you ever seen your neighbor bring in the
groceries and it's like
and they're just like coming back from
like these like meme channels it's just
pretty good it's pretty good it's a
really good
that's just the next level of hits blunt
meme
you've seen my neighbors bring in the
groceries right you know I don't think
like when do they do it maybe I'm I'm
the neighbor okay yeah it just spawns in
their fridge obviously well to be fair I
don't bring the [__] groceries back
because I just ubereats all the time
that might be another big reason as well
yeah
I just love it it's so funny yeah but
like it's weird because I think a lot of
people thought that the last job that
would be taken over is kind of like the
creative job right we all thought we We
All Fall there you know there'd be a
point where computers can get smart to
do a lot of like the specialist jobs
that we have to study for and stuff like
that but creative jobs art music that
can never be replicated and it's it's
weird seeing the kind of like the AI art
kind of like well we're going are we
going down that rabbit hole like
controversy yeah it happened within the
last last few months if anything I mean
a lot of things are automated now
physically but obviously I mean think
about it like still you have to build a
[__] robot yeah you have to build
something and test it but when you can
just run code over and over again and
keep tweaking it and keep running it on
these super computers it doesn't require
you to build anything it's like okay
well yeah it makes way more sense that
this stuff could be replicated and
something especially like music is
anyone really surprised that AI was able
to replicate music like when you think
about it it's it's not that complicated
this is coming from the guy who doesn't
make music by the way on the beeps and
boops to me to me it's not that
complicated oh my gosh now I know now I
know how the like artists feel when the
AI odd came out I am yeah I'm offended
what am I saying okay listen listen that
is okay that is a general sweeping
segment am I saying that AI music is
sounds indistinguishable no no make
something that sounds pretty much like
normal music or very passable music yeah
of course nothing like a [__]
Symphony that sounds amazing no of
course yeah you might I don't know and
like you know what I mean like is anyone
really surprised that given the tools
that we had to make music digitally
anyway that right would be able to
figure out oh hey if we just feed it a
[__] ton of information this is what
music looks like to a robot this is what
it sounds like hey give it a shot of
course it's gonna be like this yeah but
that's the thing right and I feel that's
like a a can of worms that like a lot of
people try and you know Skip around the
conversation with of like that you know
because like when that whole uh AI art
like uh programming came out you know
and it's been coming out for a while but
like about a month or so ago like you
know there was that one AI art program
that like everyone on Twitter was using
because it was like oh this is really
[__] cool to pay money for as well to
[__] scam right but it's like you
know I you know I I did it because I I
did it for a video because I thought you
know oh what kind of [__] up Creations
can this AI make of me right and you
know it was funny and you know for
entertaining purposes but then obviously
I got a lot of like backlash from like
you know the art community Unity of
being like oh so you're not going to
commission real artists but then you're
going to get art from Air that steals
other artists work and I'm just like I
hate that argument because it's like
other like human artists steal from
other human artists as well
and it's a tough conversation to have
right because it's that's a fact that
people don't want to admit no I I it's
it's it's it's it's a tough conversation
we're going into like
Uncharted Territory
AI has literally it's it's a tool so
powerful that we've had to think rethink
what is morally right right so you know
the AI training itself you know that's
building a tool that can train itself
that's that's incredible right the fact
that there's an AI can train yourself
two emulate a lot of human art and art
made by real people to the point where a
lot of it can almost seem
indistinguishable to a normal person
that doesn't understand art of course
now morally being able to train that AI
using artwork pre-existing artwork which
people have
have uh you know spent years and years
perfecting and honing their skills
um only to be added to a database to
help train this AI in order to
basically make a lot of their work
obsolete is that morally correct you
know that's that's that's something that
we've not really had to think about yet
because I don't know what kind of
press I don't know when in history we've
had I'm sure there is something similar
in history that's not going through my
head right now but it's it's a
complicated question yeah where we've
just it's it's something we've morally
not had to think about but we've now we
we now have to think about it just
because this one tool is so powerful
yeah you know and I feel it's a
difficult conversation to have as well
because it's like it's very much morally
speaking in my opinion it's very much in
a gray zone right it's like you know
there are there are benefits to this
kind of Technology you know expanding
and stuff like that in the art wall but
as well like you don't have to be an
artist to know that there are also some
demerits to it right what a out of
curiosity what benefits do you think
there is from having a IRS as opposed to
so a lot of so a lot of the kind of
backlash I guess opinions that I saw
about the whole air program coming out
from like actual artists yeah is that in
the in the odd world it's it's very much
like a lopsided kind of uh argument men
of like a lot of people look at it and
go this is a program that is stealing
you know other people's art and you know
like passing it off as like you know art
but then there are also a lot of artists
who look at programs like this and go
well okay but at this point in time it
there is still very much a a limit like
a machine limit of just how it can be
when it when it comes to creativity
right now though so right now let the
problem is that you're kind of
essentially yeah a lot of people are
like yeah it's not good enough now but
it's like okay you're You're Building
you know you're assembling the rope to
hang yourself with yeah in a sense right
because yeah and even to begin with it's
not even like they're they're being paid
they're being compensated for this
artwork being used it's that I think the
main issue is that people just haven't
consented their artwork being used to
essentially yes okay and I'm and I'm
against that personally as well of
course yeah so like the audience got
pissed off because by buying it or using
it even though you're not using it for
maybe nefarious purposes yes by using
their services you're sort of kind of
condoning it what yeah and I think
that's the problem it's probably because
like it's it's
there's been such a shift within this
just these past few months right because
at the beginning of this at the
beginning I was gonna say beginning of
this year at the beginning of last year
yeah hey I was just like haha look at
all these funny things that computers
and AIS can do oh look I search my name
and it does this and now it's getting to
the point where oh this is this can
possibly take people's like livelihoods
and jobs and now now we have to think
what is morally acceptable in terms of
how this AI has been made and how this
tool has come about okay it's like I'll
pose you a question okay so let's let's
say there's an AI that has been trained
to make YouTube videos to make anime Man
videos or something like that and it
gets to a point where your videos have
been user trained or like your videos
have been used to training I was gonna
say to make videos about anime but you
know you know
it's been trained to make videos about
Japan yes in the style of your style
yeah but it can pump it out way more
faster and way more consistently than
you could ever and if it looks and it
feels like a jury video that's a big
problem right because yeah they've
essentially used you to replace you and
then you don't get a car so I think I
think the problem is that the laws right
now and the way that it all works is
that this was never ever accounted for
yes you know that that someone could
just use your stuff and use it as
training information because normally if
you wanted to say uh learn how to play
piano like Mozart and let's say there's
video footage of it for some reason
obviously there isn't but you could just
watch it and it'll be up to you to try
and figure out how to do it yourself and
no one would bet an eye out there yes
yeah but so if you give that to a
machine and the Machine can just
replicate it one for one and spit it out
it's like okay well hold on I didn't
agree to that yeah when I publish this
video I want people to watch it I didn't
want people to [__] just replace me
with it but but I think at the same time
it's it's going to like say looking at
it from the musical standpoint right
like as someone who has been writing
music my whole life it's like I find
that as like uh you know maybe not the
best way but it is a way to kind of push
the medium further in terms of its in
terms of its current limits right it's
like okay Carly AI has gotten to the
point where it has gotten pretty close
or even similar to what humans are
capable of doing right yeah but at the
end of the day the AI at least as of
right now right there is still very much
a limit that human creativity
Cancer pass yeah so right so I think in
the sense of advancing the art medium
forward
you can look at it in a positive in that
way but at the same time as someone who
has seen AI being made also or music
being made by AI yeah it is also kind of
terrifying but at the same time at the
end of the day with any kind of like art
and stuff like that humans I think are
just naturally more attracted to
something that is made by a human even
if it might be indistinguishable of
course of course I would like to think
that yeah people like to think they're
smarter than they are and that they
would never fall for stuff like that but
yeah we do right like it's just yes I
mean it depends on the person obviously
yeah part of the real like like I said
we never thought AI would like create a
field to be one of the fields that AI
would take over first but yeah uh like
it I think it's just going it's just
kind of blowing up the fact that you
know even if you think human creativity
is beautiful and amazing which you know
I think it is it's still art is still
defined and based on rules yes and
structure you know we talk about you
know we clown on the corner for for like
how music is easy replicatable he like
at the same word
the fact that you can study music means
there is a baseline structure
um that can be learned and obviously can
be replicated and part of the beauty
sometimes comes from breaking that
structure and going going your own
Direction going against the convention
but at the same time that is also based
on the previously defined structure you
know so it's it's kind of
uh it's it it kind of is like taking all
of the gloss off and being like okay
this is what this is this this is what
your creativity actually is this is this
is all of the things but I think that's
why this conversation that's why I feel
though this conversation is so
fascinating right because it makes us
kind of question okay
what is art to begin with now like you
know it it does it's like it makes you
kind of rethink like okay what makes
this one thing artistic and this other
thing not as artistic right I think with
this specific uh controversy that
happened where a lot of people got
really upset about the air Arts because
you know I think typically online anyway
well like in the online climate right
now artists who are normally undervalued
anyway yes and don't get paid maybe as
much as they should so it was kind of
like the the cigarette butt being put
out on you and you're already down right
yeah okay so I'm already struggling to
get a fair price for my art and now I
have to compete with this [__] that's
trained off on my [__] like yeah what
the [__] like for example right uh
another AI situation um remember like I
got even like 10 years ago that Eve bot
that one where you could talk to it oh
yeah it would like flirt back to you no
there were a lot of yeah it's like the
AI chatbots you'll be like oh how you
doing today I'm fine and then you'll be
like oh you're so beautiful on it which
it was like it was like a dumb little
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah it was kind of
[__] but you're like okay well
you know you think in the time it was
like a slightly upgraded clippy
basically of course you're like this is
cool I'd love to help improve this yeah
I think the we as humans are so curious
and so fascinated by stuff that we're
like this is awesome like nobody nobody
at that time questioned yeah whether we
should get this AI better or not
everyone's like [__] yeah this is cool
yeah this is awesome this is a little
fun thing I do online with my friends
and we all laugh about it yeah and then
you think oh wait what if it gets good
enough where it can just actually scam
people online where I could just it
could DM you on Instagram yeah and it
can sound human and it can ask for your
credit card or some pointers like what
if it could have an extended
conversation with you for weeks and then
you could be scammed out of something
and it's like okay now it's like if it
gets too good because we become
normalized I mean I'd argue that's it's
already happening well I don't know if
that happens but like I mean it could
happen it could yeah the point being is
that like I think it it's concerning
when it's already too late yeah it's
already gotten to the point where it's
too good then you're like oh oh we
[__] up
this whole thing like five ten years ago
we thought that's cute that's nowhere
near as good as the stuff we're making
yeah and this was the the sentiment we
had and obviously now that it's catching
up everyone's kind of scared because
they're like where does this go yeah
where is it going to be in 10 more years
yeah I I think it was just like basic
human naivety to be like to be like oh
this thing exists oh that's that's cute
that's not a problem I'm gonna have to
worry about in my lifetime let's just
watch Sci-Fi movies about it isn't that
so funny right now and now we are in
that sci-fi so yeah there was this
[__] that was a I don't know who is
Adobe or something there's one
presentation like I don't know like two
three four years ago where it's
basically like off of X amount of
samples of your voice they could pretty
much perfectly replicate yourself yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that was
terrifying too because like now it's
like all right well deep fakes at least
those are still uh yeah they're not
great still like yeah yeah I mean you
can do some really convincing ones but
to have your voice taken feels really
weird yeah imagine that I mean yeah you
know yours is on there on one shrimp
shitty one doesn't sound yeah I mean it
doesn't get that but it can get there
yeah and yeah it just raises a lot of
like new morality questions that you
realize oh we are definitely we are
definitely not prepared
apocalypse is coming so they're able to
make a deep fake so they can make a
facial uh reconstruction if you can't
they could take your voice and then now
they have your video ideas right
um this is obviously only applies to ask
and this is dude [__] cares if our
YouTubers get [__] copied yeah
um but it's just you know yeah I think
it's no surprise that the creative
aspects are the first to be uh kind of a
mimicked or uh yeah absolutely because
it's also the average everyday person
doesn't care to interact with a robot
that could maybe fix a phone yeah right
maybe it's cool for someone else but I'm
gonna be like I'll go in the art I I'll
give it I'll talk to the funny robot
yeah why not why are we talking to
robots
why why are we humoring them
this is where the robot would be like
you're a peasant Comics
the robots feels more real than talking
to humans okay
we would go online and we would just
[__] chat to a wall right like I saw
the other day um someone had made
um an AI V tuber yeah I saw that and I
was just like it's literally just like
the whole Tay thing but just with a
voice thing there was there was a clip
that was going around where they they
played to me by name huh they mentioned
me by name and I had this clip like sent
to me everywhere and it's like this aiv
YouTuber mentioned you by name and I was
like how the [__] doesn't Joey messenger
yeah it said Joey the anime man and I
was like who who are you how do you know
me but like it's just just seeing it
that that also [__] okay so everyone
right now is at the same stage where
it's just like haha wow how cute an aiv
tube isn't this such a nice cute little
idea fine I I swear to God in like five
ten years maybe even sooner no yeah as
soon as AIS can get to a point where
they have an endearing personality it's
[__] over man being able to stay here
nice Japan will be definitely be the
first country we are we are literally we
are literally in the epicenter of
humanity getting wiped out by vtubers
manager think about Japan 100 accepted
YouTuber AI Overlord you know why
because you can't get a [__]
boyfriend
I am waiting for the niji Sanji like aiv
super division to come out and just be
like I'm sorry but Idol that will never
have a boyfriend never have any
controversy you know hopefully he won't
say anything racist I say hopefully
because God knows what the AI is going
to be trained on you know
here's the thing how do you cancel an AI
an AI is uncountable right because it
can only be trained by humans so who are
the real evil not the P or AI it's the
[__] humans that trained it man I
can't believe you hurt my feelings
my real feelings
oh my God that is very poggers yeah
bottom line everyone in the creative
field is [__] it's on 24 7. but the
bottom line everything every every
artist musician's a [__] YouTubers are
[__] everyone's [__] if you work in
uh you know some engineering or some
stuff you're pretty good when you're
using your hands yeah
I thought programmers were safe but now
there's AI that can do programming maybe
maybe we go maybe we've got to go back
to the Stone Age maybe the only jobs
that will be left is like manual labor
you know tedious manual labor you know I
can't dig a hole in the shovel can't
they
we'll just be building huts and filming
that and be like ha [__] you AI yeah
let's see you're trying to build this
primitive technology YouTubers are just
like my time has gone more except
they've they've surpassed us when they
can beat us at speed running video games
that's what I like said what do you mean
when an AI I can just speed run a video
game on its own and do like the Cheeto
Skip and all that in the video game it
can already like do but all you have to
do is just feed it a task well yeah we
have to feed it a test right that's like
a video basically playing though yeah we
can figure it out all on its own that's
when I'll be impressed when yeah when an
AI can figure out a brand new like skip
then that's when I'm impressed and I'm
like okay
a lot less out of everything that's like
ai's could do I think that might be one
of the easier things bro you got an AI
That's running a video game 24 7. have
you ever watched those machine learning
compilations of video games after like
[__] uh two to four weeks they're
still dumb as [__] really right now yeah
right now right now yeah you have to put
a lot you the AI on its own cannot learn
like you need to feed it like you need
to tell right like hey you know like if
you watch videos of it like uh racing a
car in a video game like you have to
feed it a lot to get it even remotely
good um yeah but it depends how how
quickly you can iterate upon itself
um because there's more computing power
the more it can help I guess yeah the uh
I don't know I'm not an expert in this
[__] all I know is that they are bad
Joey you should be ashamed of yourself
wow I can't believe me and about a
million other people uh joining you you
know it's like this is the problem is a
lot of other people don't have comment
sections yeah yeah but also but also a
lot of people don't read their
conversations yeah that's true you know
what I'm gonna AI I'm gonna create an AI
bot that gives me wholesome comments
that finds out exactly what porn I'm
gonna jack off to that day I'm tired of
scrolling quite frankly and I will
welcome that one it's like oh BBW today
I wasn't really gonna go for that one
but maybe I think that's just the I'm
feeling lucky button on Google
I wanted to watch the porn I'm watching
and then decide exactly what I'm into
and when I'm gonna be into it
of death because I I can't trust myself
maybe I'm just doing it for the sake it
pings you on your phone to be like J.O
time it vibrates like really
aggressively in your pocket yeah to turn
you on it's like your own time here's
the link off you go yeah and it's
already playing on your Chromecast
please enter the bedroom yeah I mean I
mean Jarvis play BBW Paul
as you get wheeled in yeah I mean
if you tell me is a feeding tube but not
something that's sucking my dick
you telling me how to do that manually
[__] that yeah
plot hole in it how are they jacking off
it doesn't look like it's possible it
would have happened if Wally was based
yeah
[__] Japan's already figured that
[__] out before the AI did
they don't get as a get into resistance
in the [__] you make sure that jacking
this video is sponsored by boxing boxer
delivers the experience of tasting all
authentic Japanese snacks candy canned
and teas sourced directly from centuries
old small family businesses right to
your door every single month they will
send you a unique box filled with the
best Suites that Japan has to offer and
we are in the brand new month of January
so of course we have the shinshin New
Year box each boxer is packed with
snacks that comes with a cultural
booklet that tells you all about the
theme where the sharks come from details
on all the flavors and it even teaches
you a few Japanese phrases which Joey
needs what have we got in there this one
I ate in my personal boxer and it's very
good but Joey tells more about it this
is a kanjugu Miyazaki mango chocolate
the mangoes come from the Miyazaki
prefecture they're extremely uh
expensive than amiyazaki mangoes and
they're absolutely delicious I'm annoyed
that that's pretty good why is it not
like five times like the one time I want
America sizes in Japan that's one bite
is not enough right but for those of you
who love your snacks boxer also offers
uh tea pairings as well this month there
is some gimme child with a little bit of
matcha in it so you can kind of get a
sweet bitter taste to match your
so if you want to try some snacks with
us and support our Channel click the
link in the description down below and
use coupon code trash to get 15 off your
first box you order thank you very much
to boxing for sponsoring us this week
back to the episode I'm taking the rest
of those have you have you like because
I don't go on Tick Tock how is this far
away I'm actually going for a jacket on
today because I got okay I don't go on
Twitter but I have I've I've seen this
happen to other people where
um they've like they've had something on
their Tick Tock which has popped up that
has been relevant to like some very
specific intrusive thought that they've
never like verbalized or anything like
that but Tick Tock is just like oh
here's a video about that one topic that
you've thought about that's coincidence
and then when you spot it it feels so
much more real than you know just yeah
it's a mixture of coincidence and the
fact that I think there are so many tick
tocks out there now that have just
covered every possible internal like
situation that could be relevant to you
okay I want an AI that tells you want my
next dark thought is gonna be
it's like an AI that like warns you
before you have the thought it's just
like stop right now you're just chilling
and you have that one thought you're
like whoa that was dark
you know you're okay come on I cannot be
alone in this you know that's just like
every year you see that on a tick tock
that's [__] up but that's cool that's
sick no because like because this has
happened to like Sydney a few times uh
where she's just like see Cindy likes to
bring up random stuff sometimes and uh
if you found out in Sydney she she says
the dog says she says every [__]
intrusive and non-intrusive thought
whether they make sense or not yeah so
one time she was uh we're just like
[__] watching TV or something and
then she just goes to me could you
survive a tsunami if you like are in a
swimming pool and you switch to the
bottom of the swimming pool and hold
your breath
should I be offended
and he was one of those statements no I
just swimming to the bottom bro
and it was like one of the that he was
one of those [__] and it was one of
those moments where I heard a statement
and I didn't even know where to begin
because I'm just I'm just like I don't
think this is even worth entertaining
the thought I'm just like I just like
what and she's like no I I think like
has anyone ever thought about that I'm
like
Sydney
and I just left that was that you know
that was like I was like I did not know
where to begin and I was just like John
left he went to his computer and he
started programming in AI
[__] you know right [__] you're not yeah
and then like two days later
um I was I was like she's lying in bed
and she'd go and she goes what the [__]
no way and I was like Sydney what's
going on
and she she runs down to me and she goes
watch this Tick Tock and a tick tock is
here's why you wouldn't survive if you
swam to a bottom of a pool during a
tsunami and I was just like I thought
that that that is that is the creepiest
[__] I've ever seen in my life and I
don't know if this was like a
subconscious Trend that was happening
during Tick Tock but I have never heard
anyone pose this question before I just
I just like to think just out of context
that Tick Tock was just one that Sydney
made like that night it's an AIT Target
it's just like check it out I'm not the
only one that's thinking this I'm not
weird right
please believe me yeah
I don't know because I don't know if
you've driven Mike when you do you only
drive a lot and you've driven a lot of
hours and then you sit there and you
have that moment where you're like
oh yeah if I [__] this up I die
yeah I've had that you know when you're
just you just drive it like you're like
you're like oh this is super chill this
is funny and you do it every day and
then you're just like oh wait I gotta I
gotta pay attention
not that I'm not paying attention yeah
but you know when you just and no one's
ever gonna get him to call me ever again
no but you know what I mean like you're
just driving and then you forget how
dangerous driving is until you have that
moment where you're like oh if I just
turn if I accidentally wasn't paying
attention I turned a little bit that way
I it would it's over it's it's that
moment [__] up why do I have those
thoughts
it was this woman and it was a woman
standing like lying on the edge of a
waterfall
someone drew quote retreated it and it
was something like nah the voices would
get me for sure
and they had like 300 000 likes
the voices
that's so dark but okay but before
before I say what I'm gonna what I'm
going to say listen everyone has dark
thoughts okay I'm I'm I I'm a safe
driver guys I'm a safe
God has driven me before
we've had we've had a road trip together
they're in one piece okay yeah so
sometimes you're on a highway right and
you see like oncoming traffic right and
you're going like 70 miles per hour and
you're and sometimes you get this
thought sometimes
all I have to do is just turn the
steering wheel slightly and everyone's
dead good thing I'm not gonna do that
but what if
you saw this place
it's just like oh good thing I'm not
gonna do okay but good thing I'm a sane
human being what if or am I or am I
everyone collectively has that thought
right everyone collectively is driving
so yes they do and everyone doesn't not
drive safe when they do yeah exactly I
know it's also like when driving
sometimes you especially in Long
stretches it's I think intrusive
thoughts is different from just being in
kind of like getting into like this
almost vegetative state where you're
just so focused on the road that you
forget that you're going at like 70
miles there's a phenomenon right where
you know some people if they drive back
to work all the time and it's a
relatively short distance some people
can forget that they even drove to work
that like they don't have the memory of
driving the car because they've done it
so many times and it's so automatic yeah
it all just Blends together it's like
have you ever had a autopilot moment in
your life where you just like for sure
you wake up from the Matrix and you're
like why did I do this I well you're
just walking and you suddenly forget
like you're walking you just you don't
like you don't you don't like have that
thought that you're actually controlling
your walking there's no there's the
moment that I'm sure everyone in the
world has experience at least once of
like you're just you know you're in the
living room and then you walk to your
room and then you enter your room and
then you just stop and you go why did I
just walk away of course of course
everyone's had that that is that is like
an autopilot moment my my brain just
pre-programmed to be like walk to yours
because like I'll never forget that
that's like that that's like every day
of my life
Welcome to ADHD everyone but like I
remember like the worst time it happened
and the part that still like freaks me
out is I remember
I remember this one time
um in University
um so you know you go to your lecture or
every single day of your [__] life
right
and then I remember leaving my house
because it was the weekend yeah and then
huh yeah ladies and gentlemen it was the
weekend and I was going to meet a few
friends in the city center
um so I start walking I put on my
earphones uh and then the next thing I
realized I look up and I'm in front of
my lecture hall and I'm like why the
[__] did I go here how did I walk it was
it was the autopilot walk today
autopilot walked to the ledge Hall and
it's not a short walk it was a 30-minute
walk what I did not notice that I was
walking to my lecture hall which is the
opposite direction to where I was going
to meet my mates until I was in front of
the lecture hall dude if that isn't
solid evidence that like fast travel
exists in real life like I don't know
what it is you just press the button and
you just he's a fast travel to the
lecture travel to the wrong place I'm
like I glitched down on my way don't you
I don't actually need to go yeah yeah
that is It's like because I'm sure
everyone has experienced that I'm just
like oh I'm here now but I don't
remember how I got here yeah I just I
just like oh I just my my feet just
started walking and I'm here now okay
that's just the pre-programmed script
just started right it's just like all
right here we go bro that's so funny
that's every time I walk back after like
a night of drinking sometimes
holy [__] I've had like insanely song
insanely long walks after I'm like
[__] pissed out of my mind yeah I
have no idea how I like get back because
I could barely like form two I could
barely form like a single step and I'm
like so I wake up next day and I
perfectly I'm always home and I always
remember getting I remember I always
remember going into my door and getting
back in but I can never remember the
journey that took me there telling you
man fast travel
it's IRL faster IRL fast travel it
exists
let's uh to keep this like existential
crisis going go on I felt it I fell into
like another weird Rabbit Hole the other
day all right what would you do if you
knew you were about to die
because okay what what span of time are
we talking are we talking like I'm gonna
die within the year or I'm gonna die
like tomorrow uh within like an hour
the hour yeah oh [__] because because I
I
um I got into jail yeah because I got
into this weird Jr
it's not oh my God
because because uh like I uh got into
this rabbit hole because I like this uh
this video was recommended to me about
the Hawaiian like kind of like the
missile alert right so uh a while ago
like Hawaii had like a fake missile
alert where everyone on their phones got
it and got an alert that said ballistic
missiles are heading towards Hawaii
right please head to shelter as soon as
possible this is not a drill
and of course terrifying it's it's like
imagine like the earthquake alerts it's
like on that except
basically you're being told that a
nuclear bomb a nuclear problem nuclear
ballistic missile bomb is heading
towards Hawaii right and Ireland where
the [__] are you gonna run yeah where
are you gonna run so four battles yeah
so for about like 45 minutes
a lot of people believed This is the End
right this is this is going to be the
end and like I I saw that video and then
I I was just it just like so curious so
I started like reading comments and
hearing stories about people who
actually experienced that and it's just
it's interesting just to see people say
like you're you're [__] brain
chemistry just had their brain chemistry
had changed after that experience just
because they had like made peace
with the fact that they were going to
die and it's I find it interesting
because you know in movies and
everything like that you you see people
portrayed as the world's coming to an
end let's all [__] Panic let's all go
out kicking and screaming but the
reality is so many people were just
um were just kind of like at peace
without accepting yeah yeah I I think
about that video of that guy who's just
playing golf oh yeah yeah I'm gonna
finish this whole of golf yeah I'm gonna
get a PB before
he like I saw that video as well there's
a guy who just starts off the video
being like if you're seeing this video I
probably didn't make it oh wow and and
he just he just starts being like you
know what I lived a good life this is
probably the end but I'm gonna finish
playing this golf I'm gonna go out doing
what I have it's such a good video what
a chat what a [__] I think I think
one of the most famous stories actually
uh Jim Carrey who was in Hawaii at the
time all right uh and he I saw a clip of
him telling his story about it as well
well what happened was he got a call
from his agent being like this is
happening
what the [__] uh so you know the first
emotion you get is like Panic yeah is
there anything I can do I gotta find my
friends gotta find my family and
everything like that
um so he tried calling his daughter I
don't think his daughter picked up or
anything like that uh but then but then
after after that initial panic's over
kind of like the acceptance kind of
comes in so then what he did was he just
he just thought to himself everyone's
trying to get out but then he just he
just said he just realized he didn't
want to die in his car right so he
walked out to the hotel and just walked
on the beach and just sat there and just
thought about everything that he was
thankful for in life and I'm like [__]
man that is that must have been an
experience that you can't like I don't
know I don't know it's
more people like I'm genuinely curious
if anyone in Hawaii
went through that experience what was
your experience because I I find that
what happened in Hawaii [__]
fascinating because it's it's kind of
like a case study of like so many people
believing that this one terrible thing
is going to happen there's one thing you
only see in like films and Cinema and
stuff like that so you don't normally
you don't really know how people are
going to react or how how you're going
through around you you can only just
like [__] think maybe I'll do this
right maybe I'll do that right and I
feel like hearing those stories as well
like you know you know first-hand
narratives is like you know they you can
you can hear and you know imagine what
they were going through but like the
actual like raw emotions that they were
going through is like that's something
you can't just like listen to and
imagine right like that's something
that's just like you need to have
experience the amount the amount of
comments I saw that was uh when I knew I
was going out I just started smoking a
fat blunt man I was I was going out high
as a guy baby
and I'm like and I am doing everything
strong imaginable before I go I will not
die sober
no no that's a good question like what
would you do
I don't know what I do try and break
every law imaginable in an hour try and
break every law environmentally be like
you know like like every dark thought
you have right it's like you know I'm
sure there are people who are like well
if we're gonna go in an hour yeah I
might as well try and fulfill that more
curiosity I've always the [__] giant
tortoise
I don't know if that's possible okay
okay I'm eating one I don't care if it's
raw okay I I I want to go out eating
good food now I've been thinking about
okay I have 45 minutes to find my
perfect Last Meal which is available in
the vicinity I'm in what the [__] what
would I go with hits honestly McDonald's
assuming that the workers are happy to
keep working when the world is ending in
45. you got to clock out no yeah do you
know how many people want Big Macs right
now I gotta give it to him
it's it's probably they're probably just
giving it away yeah exactly but I wanna
I wanna I wanna know if there's anyone
who's like anyone who [__] confessed
enough enough
there's probably someone out there but
also if if you're if you're dying and
then if the other person's dying does
confessing help at all like I don't know
because we've never been in that
situation but what what's kind of funny
to think about is like they confess
right yeah and then they didn't they
didn't so they basically just [__]
themselves okay can we google if there's
any stories of this happening I'm sure
there must have been people who like P.S
actually there's a [__] all along yeah I
[__] on your paws I wasn't a dog P.S I I
banged your mom
I want to know the wholesome stories but
also I want to know what was the most
wildest [__] that was like that happened
during that 45 minutes [__] [__] yeah
yeah I'm sure yeah some people only have
like an hour left to live I mean some
people already did break laws oh I'm not
sure yeah some people probably did and
what he got in trouble for it yeah
Jesus but they barely part of the movie
you wouldn't steal and steal a college I
will
not breaking him if I had a year to live
well I'm starting a meth Empire yeah I
hope one of you boys would be you know
my my Hank to me to me Walter White I'd
like to think so
yeah exactly it's like depending on the
that's why I was asking about the time
frame right because it's like okay if
it's like an hour right there's only so
much you can do but like say for example
if you were gonna die within the next
like say a month yeah right like I think
it would be very different I decided
I've decided what I want to do well if I
had an hour left I would film every
single hot take I have left that is
unsayable out loud and then I'll post it
and then I'll die PornHub traffic
climbed during the Hawaii missile alert
of course I'm not the only one Owen
[Laughter]
I'm going out I'm going out Bull's
emptied
all right
what time do you think I should lost
your time to go out I'm trying to find
some funny stories yeah that's such a
good question holy [__] I mean I have an
hour right I can
I mean I could go through everything
I'm like you know there'd be a part of
me that's like I wonder if I can do it
to some gay porn you know like I've
never tried so you know maybe now's the
time to like broaden my house it's time
to broaden my horizons that's just every
tag I'm gonna give it a go go
yeah this is like like because the
reason I fell into this Rabbit Hole was
reading other people's story because
there's so many like nuances and just
little things I never thought about
until I read about people's experience
about it because like yeah if I did have
30 minutes left how the [__] would my
mind go if I die if I decided to jack
off would I would I try something your
would it would I put on [__]
Masterpiece one last time for like a
Victory lap yeah
it's up to you man it's one of your
brain decide
I'd probably be too shocked to think of
anything meaningful in one hour you know
when I was a not a lot of time no you
probably just go back to top right I
mean we've already talked for now you
can't even you can't even finish a
[__] trash teeth episode
like oh I have one hour to live I can't
wait to watch my favorite Treasure
episode
no you can watch it two times speed yeah
I got it Mom I can watch one YouTube
video before bed the YouTube video
oh my god oh but yeah I mean it's it's
it's interesting just
or we have these interesting case yeah
exactly close to one hour marker just in
case so right the one at all it's I
think we were about to like reach the
one hour mark so yeah hopefully you put
on this episode if uh missile will cry
if if you're getting like an alert or
something like that a false missile a
false
I wonder if it would ever come back to
bite if it ever did happen again in
Hawaii there's a missile look but it was
actually legit if people didn't believe
it
yeah unfortunately being on an island is
probably one of the worst places you
could be during a missile yeah well um
well it's not even like if you had an
hour anyway even if you're on Mainland
and it was coming for you if there's any
meaningful Direction you could get to an
hour yeah yeah exactly like that's like
that's like two blocks in New York City
you know what I mean yeah you can barely
get out of New York
you can barely get out without a uh
crisis happening and let's say even if
you were in a metropolitan area or or in
a city or whatever if there was a
missile Alert in a city you're not
getting out of the city because
everyone's trying exactly yeah like
everyone's gonna try and leave yeah so
obviously you know we saw that with
covid everyone try to leave certain
cities were being locked down yeah yeah
it's just like we see that even some
things like this that the infrastructure
just crumbles when this many people want
to use it yeah yeah it's like I I I
think would I be that guy who panic
makes and runs or would I just be the
guy who accepts my fear I'll probably be
I think I'll be the guy who accepts my
yeah you for sure would yeah yeah I'm
like I've lived a good life guys you
would go to the wine fridge pop one open
and just and just look outside the
window dude and you were just you would
just swivel the line and Timmy fat I
join you all right yeah like probably go
on my rooftop or something like that I
didn't know it yeah and and just like
swelmed like my last glass of wine or
something like that and just be like
[__] yeah it's a beautiful day not one
good bottle you've been saving for that
occasion yeah I know especially if
you're in [__] Hawaii imagine how Zen
people must have felt oh in the climate
you know it feels I can't imagine how
depressed we would be in [__] England
with like the rain coming down it'd be
like no that's a fitting end
that's like everyone just like
conglomerates to the Palm it's just like
the collapse it was a good one bro that
that would happen that wouldn't happen
everyone would go to the nearest [__]
Pub and get that last fighting yeah and
ironically way to get out yeah yeah
cracking a cold one with the boys what
if he had one week what if I would have
had one week one week to live what are
you doing oh and let's let's say that
not everyone has one week it's just you
just me so everything is is available
and everything is normal right
um so like you know you could get on a
plane you could do all this stuff but no
fast travel obviously no fast travel
literally just within the like bounds of
what you can do now and money isn't an
issue okay ah well first obviously
you've got to visit your yeah I would I
would go to my family first obviously
that would take like a few days off my
schedule boom three days gone three days
gone off your schedule three days off my
schedule sorry what's the run you gotta
optimize this am I staying in England
all the time
[Music]
but I'm like hey I'm the one with the I
think what I would want is to go
somewhere that's always been like at the
top of my bucket list and then go with
my family and then just be like I did it
I I made it to the place I've always
wanted to go I'm with the people that I
care about I'm in this beautiful place
I've always wanted to go yeah I'm good
you know I do I would like
I would record a bunch of YouTube videos
that I would set to be public like one
five ten years off my desk yeah that's
what I would do that
I'll be like guys it's uh I would have
been like 32 years old I would have been
like 35 years old now how's it going on
YouTube is it still over Marianne this
man is a YouTuber is this size still
active I don't know oh my God yeah
genius content as well oh [__] yeah has
to be paid himself dividends for that
yeah
one year and then five years yeah that's
genius you should do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh he uploaded the video that
would go public you know on yeah
have you ever thought about like kind of
documenting because there's been few
there's been these kind of people who
like take taking a picture like every
day of their life for example yeah yeah
plus we do document our lives so that's
kind of thing
we literally that was a stupid question
we literally have thousands of hours of
us our lives are two documents against
the point where I have no memory of
filming some videos I have no memory of
a good chunk of videos I do not remember
filming them how the process was at all
no and now I completely understand why
these people who've been creating their
entire life are like I have no [__]
memory of making that thing because I
get it like my video my YouTube video is
like six years ago if you told me do I
have any memory of making that no memory
no no memory not at all I've made so
many but even not just like Memories
like
it's it gets harder to remember some
like just normal days of your life you
know even if if you ask me hey what did
you do last Wednesday you'd really have
to like think back to it right I don't
actually know what I did last week yeah
what did you do last Wednesday what's
the date
I was on a plane yeah I was
still sick dying yeah I was dying
because and that's just like last week
you know you think you'd remember what
you did last week in good detail but
then go back like what did you do what
what did you do two birthdays ago what
was your birthday celebration and then
you go back even further and you just
realize how little of your life you
[__] remember and it's one of the
reasons even though like I don't take
photo I don't take many photos I've
never been a guy who has taken photos
and it's kind of like I kind of realized
how much it's bitten me in the back now
just there is so many like there's
there's been a lot of trips that I've
not kind of let's say documented or
taken a lot of photos off except for
maybe one photo on my phone yeah and
I've just completely I have nothing
I have nothing that to remind me of that
trip you know I have nothing to remind
me of that memory because I thought
I I had this like I thought before it's
just like if the Trip's good the
memories are weird baby I got the
memories stored up in here baby that's
what makes it special and I'm like [__]
nah that that was a [__] life
should be like allow me to introduce
myself like I'm sure if this the trip is
special enough for the boys I'm never
gonna forget it yeah I don't even
remember half the [__] that happened on
tour okay
yeah half the days
yeah I think I don't even remember every
venue God if we didn't so I didn't film
it I wouldn't remember half the [__] we
did on our road trip special yeah it's
just I remember watching that car the
road trip special and being like Oh yeah
we oh yeah
oh yeah we did I did say that I
completely forgot that we spent an
entire day in like a Germantown racing
go-karts and [__] like that until I saw
it in the special oh my God yeah I had
that when I when I first saw that drop I
was like oh we did go here
I remember that because I remember like
trying to Ram you off the road oh yeah
that's right I I completely forgot about
like the swan boat though oh yeah yeah
right like it's like we were old enough
for like like 20 minutes at least 20 30
minutes yeah the bread was good though
the bread was good it was good yeah not
like and I guess that's why you know I'm
I'm kind of glad that I've gotten more
into the habit of just like taking
photos because it's like even if it
might not seem important now yeah that's
[__] you look back five ten years from
now and being like Oh yeah you know that
wasn't important or anything like that
it wasn't important event or a special
place or anything but just seeing that
is like yeah that was nice because also
sometimes you get photos of maybe bad
times and you're like [__] I hate that
well I mean that those times you know
you could just be like well you know it
happened so yeah you just yeah because
I've I've always like never felt the
need to take photos because I'm like
everyone around me takes photos and they
upload it to Facebook but hey surprise
surprise no one uses Facebook anymore if
you're like our age so I'm like well
[__] if other people takes photos oh my
God I don't post it and parents on
Facebook now sorry I just remember maybe
we use Facebook appearance yeah yeah
it's not funny how that happens well
Facebook used to be this like hip cool
thing and now it's the thing that is
just showing his age yeah yeah I think
that it's Facebook has become the
platform that your parents use and you
use to keep in touch with your older
generation of parents and stuff like
that I'm glad my parents aren't on
social media
so glad I I'm also glad really really
glad holy [__] I'm glad I blocked my dad
on social media I thought your dad
blocked you no you blocked no I blocked
him yeah I I I I look back and I'm like
yep you know back then I was I was
annoyed that they didn't understand
social media and now I'm like thank God
my parents aren't on Facebook on on
Twitter aren't doing on posting [__]
yeah I don't want to see them but I
guess my kid will be like why is my dad
always been on social media his whole
life
it's like everyone at school knows
everything about I share a video of my
dad hitting the dab when he's 20.
because because like you know I've have
you seen like pictures of your parents
and stuff like that when they were young
yeah and stuff yeah I like that resource
video of why do you your parents even
look old in their younger pictures yeah
yeah that's true I haven't seen that one
well think about it like when you see
pictures of your parents when they're
young they look old still right they
look old even when they're like 20. or
when you look at pictures of like 19
what was like high school kids in the
70s they look old they look older for
some reason than high school kids today
and it's and yeah and it's this weird
like cycle I mean obviously there's a
resource video but like it's like weird
psychological
trick that happens of like because it's
from an older time yeah you initially
condition yourself to look at that and
be like that is an older person yeah
from before but they still look older
because your only image of that is this
thing is old well like also what I find
would what I'm going to find interesting
going forward is that
um
the world was just never as well
documented as it is now don't they look
older
that's high school they don't they don't
look like high schoolers right yeah like
this dude I mean doesn't look like a
high school
I think I think it looks oh just because
of the just because of the aesthetic
right because you're not sure yeah but
that's what I'm saying Okay okay then I
get it because I I look back right I
think back and I see photos like that
and it just feels old because I can't
imagine living in that time zone because
you have like the [__] serpia filter
everyone looks same video you mean sorry
it looks like it's going through like a
sepia filter everyone looks different
the haircut's different and I can't
imagine it being in like 4K HD you know
what I mean right like I I can't like I
can't imagine looking around and being
like oh this is what it looks like in
normal colors in 4K HD and [__] like
that right right which is why when I see
like have you ever seen like old videos
that have been remastered with like
modern colors yeah yeah it freaks me out
so much right yeah it's like that um
there's videos that where it's like some
One filmed like Japan in like 1910 yes
I've seen that and then they just it's
4K yeah recolored remastered it's cool
and it freaks me out because I'm like
people are freaked out like what the
[__] is that thing yeah there's that
camera because you look at this video of
like I think there's like one of like
Kyoto in like the 1890s or something
yeah and it's just weird to think like
oh every single person in this video is
not here anymore yeah and that's like
terrifying it's so weird don't say that
yeah it's so weird they're characters
okay
PCS history the whole NPC they're all
NPCs everyone is a history mpz that only
exists in the [__] books okay
yeah it's it's so like it's just so
fascinating I had that thought with like
World War II right like yeah growing up
oh yeah you had like uh grandparents and
stuff in here and then now it's slowly
getting the point where like in a few
years or you know in like 10 something
years whatever it's like the there's
gonna be so little World War II um
survivors and within like 20 30 years
there'll be no World War II yeah that's
weird to think about yeah growing up you
you'd always see them on like TV and
they would talk about it and you're like
this is like a thing yeah and then now
there's nobody who remembers it nobody
who was there yeah you can recount that
time period yeah like this extremely
important historical event when nobody
was alive for it yeah like that's so
weird going from having people alive to
it to then not having people alive like
especially in our time right because
obviously we can speculate what the
Romans were like and stuff but no one in
our time knows anyone who was ever alive
doing that you know what I mean like
weird thinking that that's it's like and
and it's like you know that's how that's
there's always I always find that
there's this disconnect with history
right where you know it happens you you
know that these people existed but they
they also just kind of feels feel like
characters in the book that's why it's
also cool having this much documentation
right because like I think the older the
history is the more scarce options we
have to figure out exactly right so we
have to like fill in the pieces
ourselves sure for sure but like what I
find interesting is that I have this
image of my parents when they were like
younger right and you have like I have
like stories that I've heard from like
uncles and aunties and some old pictures
but at the end of the day it's still
just an image of what they were like I
don't actually know what they were like
you know
um our kids are gonna [__] like our
kids are gonna have like every single
like they're gonna have like every
argument we've had about bone and
chicken and like if if my kid doesn't
like chicken wings he's gonna [__]
know why oh my dad how old is your how
old is your grandma
oh my grandma on my dad's side is around
97. okay okay this is a weird thing
right your grandma that is 97 is like an
age-wise was is closer to like the
Victorian area than like today yeah from
the moment she was born right isn't that
weird to think that Victoria that we
think of that really quirky time like
[__] weird where they were doing
weird [__] they were playing like
asbestos in their wallpaper yeah and
everything it's like you know it's just
weird to think there are people who are
alive today who are old who are closer
to these really far off periods in
history that we think is far off because
we're born now yeah we think 150 years
ago that's crazy you know what I mean
yeah um like also there was a great
video where it was like a like 1960s or
50s this woman who was like 90 and she
was recounting stories of the Victorian
period because obviously at that time it
was still you know it was still around
yeah
right yeah weird it's just so strange
geez that's yeah there's videos of these
people talking about those times so
strange yeah and it's weird like you
know going back to like ancient history
is weird to think
we can't we can't really process in in
our minds just how old like ancient
Egypt was you know yeah because you get
to a point in history and you think oh
it's all like around the same period
it's all like Roman Roman history Greek
history ancient you know ancient
Egyptian history so it's all the same
because it's all history but like it's
isn't it like the ancient Egyptians were
as all to the Romans as the Romans are
to us yeah something along those like
that like some great civilization make
it feel like it's all one blur yeah when
you actually look at the time between
you like whoa yeah I think yeah because
I think I saw something similar whereas
like it was a lot like that but like say
with like the dinosaurs right of like I
think it's something like in our heads
we think like Tyrannosaurus Rex and
stegosaurus are just like yeah they were
around the same time like it's it's you
know it's all during the dinosaur era
yeah but in actuality I think between
the stegosaurus and the Tyrannosaurus
Rex there's like 400 million years oh no
we're uh humanity is a [__] footnote
compared to how long the dinosaurs yeah
the world but it's just so crazy to
think that it's like yeah they're the
same thing they're around the same time
and it's just not even like we like to
think that we're better like huh look at
these dumb animals they got wiped out by
[__] media bro we've like hardly
we've barely lived the amount of like we
have been we live have lived a fraction
of the time they have Ruled the Earth
yeah and then all it took was like one
[__] day and they're like gone you
know it's it's because they didn't get
along
we wiped out more of us than anyone else
all right
no meteor can take that away from yeah
that's we killed way more of us than
that [__] dumb meteor ever would have
all right there's just four flexing on
the meteorite we are the best at killing
us yeah without now no one is better
than us that's why I was smart just to
[__] kid however if the ants decided
to have an uprising we would be [__]
oh absolutely absolutely if the answer
decided they have had enough of being in
the ground if the insect world decided
to start a coup d'etat one day like they
can overtake us in a day well that just
that just [__] remind me do you know
something weird I've been doing in the
holidays are you collecting ants
um I haven't been collecting thank God I
would have been this is I do not want to
get it I'm not mailing don't worry about
that
I've been I've been reading a book
like in 2023 like like a book book like
wow words like not not even like a light
novel like a heavy like no pictures like
no pictures wow it's just a heavy novel
so yeah I've been reading this uh sci-fi
uh sci-fi novel called children children
of time you ever heard of this book
it's I but maybe you have maybe you
haven't I don't know I just uh I I
um I know you haven't you don't read I
hear what people talking about oh okay
oh my God what are those funny things
yeah I mean it's I've heard of a book
before you know those it's it's like
read about a book yeah it's a
fascinating read uh because I I heard
something I heard something about the
book that kind of like piqued my
curiosity uh because it explores the
idea of like what
what aliens actually are and what's
Evolution actually is right so uh the
premise the premise of this book right
is Humanity at the beginning of Like A
Flat Earth a conspiracy theory yeah what
is evolution let's break it down let's
pray let's break it down so it it poses
this question so it's the book is set in
like the Far Far Future where humanity
is like an advanced race or something
like that and there's this one person
who just goes let's let's do an epic
experiment
um let's try and give monkeys these
virus this virus that speeds up
Evolution put them on a planet and see
what happens okay and then I one day and
then eventually when they become as
smart as us I will come down and be
their new Gods right okay
um but unfortunately sorry Connor the
the plan goes wrong all the monkeys dies
uh but what happens instead is that
spiders instead get infected by this
virus all right that just kind of like
just speeds up evolution and
um
and uh speeds up Evolution and knowledge
basically like that um so what happens
is it follows why spiders [__] man
that's like the worst people to get
events but that's that's why spiders
because when we think of what is alien
to us like what is more alien to us and
un understandable than spiders and it's
fascinating to think for one it may like
it cemented the realization that if
aliens exist there's no [__] way we'd
be able to communicate with them or like
or like have any resemblance to us
whatsoever
um because it really like it it follows
this spider civilization that emerges
from like I guess their Stone Age to
their Modern Age right and it shows how
different basically everything in their
civilization would be
um from like human civilization
um just based on what spiders are so
like a great example is it of this is
like Midway through the book slight
spoilers but it's only like a small
scene Midway through the book uh one of
the advanced humans crash land on this
planet right
um and the spiders kind of like they
they take they they take this human in
and they start studying this human
um and they come to the conclusion that
humans must be [__] dumb man because
there's no there's no way that spot that
there's no way that it can communicate
right
um because spite of the way spiders
communicate is they don't have ears they
communicate through vibrations yeah so
they form this communication system with
vibrations through their webs to
communicate complex ideas to each other
and there's humans who's this human who
is barking
voice like Sound Vibrations to them
they're like nah there's there's no way
any animal would use sound as a
vibration like medium that's that's dumb
why would people do that yeah and
there's no way that any animal would any
animal would evolve
um an orifice that they use to
communicate and also ingest food that
just seems sub-optimal why would any why
would I know any animals do that and the
spiders come to the conclusion that
humans are these uh dumb animals that
have not like reached Evolution
everything like that and it's just
there's so much about this book that
like opens your mind and like makes you
rethink what is it about like our
society and our civilization that as
that is based on us basically coming
from [__] monkeys and everything like
that so basically if
ants do like decides do an uprising it's
probably going to be a different kind of
[__] Uprising than anything that we
can [__] imagine and everything like
that I don't know like I think it's easy
to think that Evolution just stops
because you're like everything I get it
now I understand how every animal is and
how we are but obviously it's kept it's
been going on for millions of years and
it'll probably keep on going yeah people
will get like [__] Tails I'll be sick
we might grow another arm who knows
who knows where humanity is going to be
in like millions and millions of years
if we live as long as if we live as long
as the dinosaurs that would be pretty
interesting I'd like to think the
spiders are watching me and they're like
what is he doing it's just me watching
like
Dave
this must be a complicated human ritual
[Laughter]
yeah it's just like that Meme where it's
just like you know people look back on
the memes and they try to study like
[__] low cap images or something this
must have been some ancient religious
text or something like that do you think
that actually happened with like the
Angels yeah yeah yeah yeah we've I swear
they've been studying cases where we
thought it was something we were so
wrong multiple times because obviously
you get more information and you you
know the world's become more connected
and it's you know a lot of information
that we had in English was based off
like wrong accounts and all also
resources that weren't really great and
so now we can we can translate and stuff
so it's much better yeah not that we're
doing right now could you imagine if
like some archaeologist was just like
stunning like ancient Egyptian like
hieroglyphs it can be like oh we we
still haven't like uncovered what this
meaningful message must be because they
left it on this wall and then you you
know you go back 4 000 years and this
suggestion is just like
I said
what are these strange golden like M
Signs they've put everywhere yeah they
seem to be there must be the cult of M
they should be in every place in Mass
it's been some ancient religion yeah a
really crucial part to the human's
existence
you know what I mean we found sir we
found more golden M's lying around what
could it mean there's so many of them
what could it mean there's so many in
this one continent in America there
seems to be a density of these
oh my god oh man it's uh
yeah it would be interesting to think
it's like a [__] sick book though
they should make that into an anime
they're not okay honestly it's like if
you if if you like me kind of sounds
like terraformers but less anime because
like the terraformers if it was smart
yeah it's terraformers if it like
there's there's so many interesting
ideas like eventually the spiders
um learn how to make computers but they
learn how to make computers via
programming like ad programming like
programming ants off this [__] [__]
which I'm just like I never thought
about it like that but if you could
learn to program ants via because ants
ants have like a real ants have a set of
programming right it's you think about a
normal Ant and the stupid as [__] but
somehow ant colonies if you study ant
colonies they're able to do some [__]
incredible things dumb individuals smart
together we should make ant AI
or would it be real intelligence no AI
stands for ant intelligence
dude when the ants see what we did to
them they're gonna be pissed they see
all these tick tocks people owning them
bro it's over dude it's over
oh my God it's like I'm sorry Malin this
uh she's the person
like all the pesticides right they
already evolve to kind of be Beyond it
and we're constantly chasing the next
one yeah we'll get to the point where
using this pesticide is just not
feasible because it's so dangerous to us
yeah uh well if you think about it so
many like modern inventions and
everything are based on nature itself
because Nature has figured out how to do
this yeah man yeah so they're trying to
make like this smart machines like
Engineering Systems where they're based
on like uh real life structures because
like a like where they try and make uh
these like kind of RC planes that are
based more off like Wing structure like
birds yeah yeah exactly yeah obviously
over Evolution they've evolved a way
that works best yeah because because one
day some dude looked up to this guy saw
a bird flying and went I won't do that
no it's like how do you like that's how
it started yeah makes you wonder like
how would you how would you would planes
be any different today if Birds just
didn't exist right so we just don't have
that framework if they just wasn't an
animal yeah it's the way that like a
plane works is very different well I
guess well they have wings right well
yeah I mean it's
like I guess what part of engineering
you care about I mean because it's like
we just stuck a [__] explosion on
there because we couldn't figure out how
to do it in a way yeah it works the way
that they do it so we had we had a strap
[__] jet fuel that it burns you know
what I mean
but like the Wright brothers didn't have
that right they they steam I think no is
it steam oh no diesel no it was diesel
sorry of course it was pretty in diesel
engine yeah Kai look it up yeah it's
probably a diesel engine right we're
getting to the point of trash days where
we're just kind of like spewing [__]
over the bed because it was like it was
like they had the a compact and
lightweight enough system that could
that made it so you could power that
right and all you need to do is make an
aerofoil which is basically just
something that just catches the most
drag yeah
um and then you just [__] power It
Forward
all right all right yeah you know small
explosions all the way yeah Humanity
since the beginning boom that's that's
all that's all we love everything they
saw an explosion they saw momentum and
they went what if we just attached that
to something
you that's how you want to make a
lightweight system now it is getting
closer and closer in a sense to either
either the the amount of power we can
generate or the size of electricity
needs to improve a lot or you kind of
get it closer to I suppose you can get
it's like a bird wing and you can maybe
get it more perfect in the sense there
yeah but it depends what you want to do
because Birds can't like uh Birds a lot
of the time coach flap in place right
like if you want a drone yeah stop birds
don't do that I mean besides but
hummingbirds do yeah right but then how
do you how do you like generate that
yeah certain dragonflies and stuff yeah
dragonflies are the best flyers in like
nature holy [__] like I sometimes I see
a dragonfly fly maneuver and it's insane
yeah yeah
you just reminded me like I mean they
made mid-flight yeah I'm like that's
hippie like it literally now that I
think about I remember as a kid thinking
like dragonfly flights patterns look
like they're pre-programmed yeah
yeah he literally like [__] that's
incredible yeah I guess yeah depending
on what kind of plane you'd want to make
but what it would need to do you'd pick
the aerofoil right on the face I guess
you could there's nothing saying you
couldn't make a dragonfly-esque system I
think you just need it all to be
balanced and you need a way to power
that much force yeah
also that'd be a lot of G's I think if
you're whipping around that fast yeah
yeah don't don't dragonflies go through
like the the most IG force or something
animals going from static to room yeah
yeah that's a lot that's a lot yeah no
we're not good at that well obviously
because we've got [__] legs and we're
heavy dragonflies are [__] light of
[__] yeah but also often a lot of times
like birds and like like um a lot of the
times their skulls kind of evolve to do
certain things like um woodpeckers they
just wrap their tongue around their
brain to absorb it you know that are you
serious your tongue wraps around their
brain
that's right I'm trying to Google this
[__] that's crazy
if you like got into a car crash and
you're just like hold on I'm Gonna Save
myself from getting an aneurysm that
legit yeah look at this look at the
diagram the the tongue wraps around the
brain oh that's epic [__] like give some
kind of cushion to their brain because
like they just like nature just [__]
up hentai like concept you know what I
mean that's
what is that okay okay explain that
concept to me let's break it down
[Music]
tell me that or something tell me the
plot what's the plot oh [__] awesome
yeah that's something new man
hey I can't call for that [__]
[Laughter]
we [__] up Humanity we've trained an
AI to like come up with [__] with brain
with brain wrapped tonguing brain
wrapped oh my God yeah maybe she's
thinking of all different types of
planes now it makes me wonder how how
did how did the invention of like the
helicopter how did that get like dude
that's actually a [__] [__] sick
history uh because the guy who made it
is a [__] psychopath he just was like
you have to be like I look like
helicopter he was like determined to die
like if you look at the history of like
the models of how I made it I swear one
of the dudes who was trying to make it
was like actually insane yeah like it
crashed so many times right but he just
kept trying to make more because he was
like dead set on it there's also like a
genius invention really yeah yeah I mean
I I mean I I don't I I fully believe
that because I look at a helicopter and
you're just like that shouldn't fly I
like I don't know what I'm talking about
we're living in a simulation I always
thought helicopters were way cooler than
planes I was a helicopter gang all the
way wait how was team helicopter I do
not have this like you just you just
like when I saw like a battle helicopter
I think that's just purely based on the
fact that like you don't see you don't
see helicopters as often as planes yeah
sure and all the helicopters you see are
kind of lame they're all kind of like
you know normal ones but they're
actually the ones with guns like whoa
something in your boy brain you're like
oh that's cool
I think it's also just the like the idea
of the helicopter let's let's spin this
thing so [__] kind of fast that we
could fly as a kid I'm just like yo I'll
just fly but stain yeah just just stay
in the air yeah planes you're just like
it's got a [__] engine to like making
her pew pew pew I don't [__] care
about that let's try spinning some
[__] blades to get you up in the air
that's metal as [__] man yeah you know
that's badass yeah which makes all the
more funny when have you seen those
videos where you see like the helicopter
like taking off but like the frame rate
of the camera shutter speed yeah so it
just looks like it's staying still
someone just turned ground yeah it just
looks like it's suspended in the air and
just like going up
the first person to discover that is a
genius it's like a [__] Looney Tunes
walk you through the camera and they're
like what the [__] well I mean uh I mean
it happens a lot natural like so when
we're filming now right like obviously
uh a lot of light flickers yeah you know
you're in Japan I don't know which side
you're on it's either flickering 50
times a second or or 60. yeah right
obviously it's not actually like fully
going on off but it's you know and
sometimes on camera you set the hurts
um if you set the shutter speed to the
wrong thing or yeah you have it on maybe
a different anti-flicker mode yeah
you'll see it like the waves yeah
appearing on them so sometimes you can
even actually seeing like flickering
slips yeah you see it pretty [__] bad
I've got a lot of video footage where
it's happened and you're like God damn
it's [__] unusable yeah it's [__]
flickering yeah well there's a there's a
lot of that you know the human sensors
can't take in there's so many like
spectrums of light and everything like
that I imagine if you could see [__]
infrared and that's [__] sick like I
love the um you know the mantis shrimp
yeah I [__] love that that thing's
cool it's one of my favorite things
that's one of my favorite animals of all
time yeah that's the stories of it
busting glass because it's just it like
it's like boils the air yeah yeah
it literally creates almost like a
nuclear explosion from how fast it moves
in terms of in Terms like the heat and
pressure it creates it's just like boom
it's like a sonic boom basically yeah
it's Sonic moves yeah it's kind of crazy
that like fish could evolve to that I
wish we [__] evolved to that yeah
I'm just like yeah I look at the mantis
shrimp and I'm just like [__] we go
wrong yeah wait wait where the [__] did
we go wrong you know because like how
One shrimp one shrimp in history saw a
clam and thought the only the most
optimal way to get inside this clam is
punching the [__] out of it I'm like
that's isn't it crazy on paper if I
asked you can't yeah do you want
intelligence or do you want an arm that
can [__] boil air you'd be like I I
would like the arm that boils yeah I
would like to see every color please
there's more colors I can't see and then
then these [__] little shrimp but
they'll just on the [__] ocean floor
yeah and we're the ones who evolved well
isn't that [__] dumb because when I'm
playing I feel about this when I'm
playing d d I'm like I'm like man
obviously I'm gonna spec into like
Wizardry or like Charisma I never put
anything in intelligence because they
always get it no they always get it
wrong in video games intelligence should
be way more op in video games yeah this
is humanity is what happens when you try
to balance out all the skill points
we just average on everything compared
to the Animal Kingdom we put all of our
stats into intelligence yeah we can't
even appreciate that yeah we're not
intelligent enough to appreciate that at
all right all the points in intelligence
and the ability to throw things that's
pretty much everything we did yeah yeah
we're pretty good at running
well I mean compared to like a cheetah
well that's the thing a lot of animals
like opposable thumbs that's pretty
[__] op yeah a lot of animals can't
run like marathons oh that's true we can
run for pretty long I mean I can't
I didn't get that some of us some of us
are pretty [__] beautiful
I'll let them do it I'm I'm I expect
into the intelligence trees all right
all right sorry I don't want me
do you know humans have a no way of
sensing wetness no I heard that oh I saw
this we just know there's like we can
tell the temperature different though
yeah yeah
I saw that yeah I found that really
interesting because I'm like how many
other things can't I sense but I can
just sense like sense a bad take when
you have it guys that's another thing
you can't say it's a dark thought before
we haven't built those receptors yet I I
can sense whether a fart is gonna smell
or not very far
that's really yeah I think I'm pretty
confident
I I like you're like test it better
what's your Source I I made it the
[__] I feel like I just know I just
know when a father's gonna smell okay
this is this is something in my my bow
tells me
do you feel like you can tell if
someone's looking at you yes yes why why
why do we feel like we can tell like
I've had I've had points where I've been
like asleep or just like napping or
something and I'm like someone's looking
at me I look up and someone is I think
going wait who is that someone okay well
that's okay that's [__] first of all
I think that's just coincidence
I think we take a note to like again I
think we saw some previous episodes um
we're like again with extremely socially
focused animals yeah and so I think
that's like an evolutionary trait that's
kind of been like malfunctioned a little
bit where we don't I guess we kind of
still need it but we don't need to be as
socially accepted as we once needed to
yeah so we were very attentive to
anything social for the most part so I
think when when people are staring at us
we're really apparent of it and we're
really bad at even like thinking Scott
just staring at me like I feel like God
was just staring at me right yeah yeah I
feel like you're just looking at my
direction I saw in the corner of my
mouth
overthink it yeah we can kind of sense
if like someone is Feeling Again a
certain way or like if a situation is
uncommon that's my [__] theory that
could be totally wrong I'm pretty sure
that's where it comes from is that we're
very very in tune with being socially
yeah I mean like you want to know if you
ask any other animal it's like uh so can
you tell if that prawn is feeling then
they'll be like no I can't give a [__]
what does that mean why would you why
would you need to sense that God dogs
are [__] cute though I wonder if a
dog knows a dog knows I'm staring at it
a dog noise
I mean it always knows it always like a
dog can always tell like when when when
when you're like giving it some
attention you could be on the other side
my dog used to do that when it was just
like kind of just sitting there just
like staring off into Blank Space
sometimes I would just you know look at
my dog because I'm like you're a good
boy you're a pretty boy and then
sometimes the dog would just kind of do
this like
walk over at me like what what do you
want every every time you know like I'm
I'm torn right in my head and whether I
think God exists because I'm like okay
God makes stuff that that kills children
and I'm like that's pretty [__] out
yeah but then we also have videos like
dogs cuddling people who are sad and I'm
like well how do you explain that you
know why the dog evolved to know when
we're sad and it helps us that's pretty
I feel like somebody must have helped
that out come on yeah we don't we don't
deserve it you know look what we've done
in history do we really deserve that we
don't maybe we should not think of God
as this omnipotent meaning that knows
everything maybe if there is a God in
this world they can make mistakes
um and I'm just saying dog like when
they created the dog that was like I
this is the biggest W of my [__] life
this is the only reason why we accept
NTR because dogs exist I think we'd all
be done I think they would have been
that would have been the final straw
there needs to be an equal evil to
create an equal Doctor Who has bought
this omnipotent power so much time yeah
frankly you know and I I I and people
who are allergic they got done dirty
yeah but they came alive yeah and then
[__] like God was listening to
[__] Metallica one day and I was like
[__] mantis shrimp man I'm gonna make
one of those let's [__] do it there's
some whack [__] that has been like
evolutionized so you're like that that
is interesting
the Mantis trip is certainly one of them
yeah like this feels like the most over
engineered Evolution to a problem right
like
right when you think about it you're
like this feels like respect far too
much for no reason it's it's like I look
at the mantrum though the reason I love
the mantis shrimp is I don't think it's
the most optimal way to achieve what you
want to achieve which is get food yeah
but I respect the fact that you
committed so hard to this one solution
yeah like you look at you know an animal
like a highly intelligent animal like an
octopus right that is like all right you
know it can problem solve it can like
you know figure out more intelligent
ways to catch its prey like camouflage
or like tricking its prey meanwhile
mantis room is like I punch hard
I destroyed I like the fact that for
some reason obviously it makes sense
evolutionary wise but just owls could
just [__] turn their head mostly all
the way around yeah yeah that feels like
the owl was kind of been a little lazy
all right I'm not gonna lie I feel like
the owl could have maybe just turned
around a little bit just
all right you know it's like no I'm not
moving my body you really need to turn
up like if I could turn my head all the
way around do I really need that I feel
like it I don't know man to be honest if
someone asked me hey would you want the
ability to very much a shower thought
yeah would you want the ability to turn
your head almost 360 degrees Yeah I'd be
like I don't know when I'd use it but
sure well why not what I want to know is
you know we we talk about like animals
and food chain and even if you don't
like an animal or something we love
talking animals yeah we love animals
animals are sick
um having said that is there a single
redeeming quality of a mosquito or can
we remove mosquitoes and
I'm sure something will be effective
there'll be no adverse effects at all I
think I remember seeing like some videos
about that of like some like experts
argue that we can but with like a little
bit of a of a deficit to the food chain
and then there are others that say like
no it's just completely if we've learned
anything we are really [__] bad at
getting involved with the [__] and
trying to control nature we've been
we've historically have a terrible
tracker yeah yeah
um yeah which is pretty bad in it kind
of the sentiment
um we shouldn't do it we're just like
what if we just make this animal extinct
it won't it won't [__] up the food chain
right the animal Kingdom's like what are
you doing stop
I know they're delicious
very precisely and you're [__] it up
I just want to know if there's any
anything any animal anything that has
something positive to say about
mosquitoes well do animals hate
mosquitoes problem so I'm sure even
spiders like I mean I eat them but I can
go without it flies too flies you know I
I can live without mosquitoes you know I
don't know
hard to say man is there anything cooler
than a mantis shrimp I don't think so
I'm I'm a Google is now coolest animals
well there's that there's that video of
the guy who was like out fishing in a
canoe and he like fit he accidentally
fished up a mantis shrimp and it like it
quickly like flicked him in the in the
toe like just like oh yeah he broke it
and it broke his top yeah I almost saw
that and he's like he's like and then he
like releases it back in and like his
foot is bleeding and then later on he's
like I I'm in the hospital because uh my
toe is broken I'm like what the [__]
it's pretty [__] wild yeah that's
wild
God I think I think I've evolved to just
drink tea it's just it's just British
isn't it I was on the plane back uh from
my Christmas break and I swear to God it
was embarrassing the amount of tea I
drank I just kept asking for more tea
and they were like and they came around
and they were like T I was like yes
bring it I think I drank like 15 Cups of
Tea holy [__] isn't that insane why is
that because I was just I was thirsting
for some hot liquid
it's what I like all right honestly ever
since moving to Japan I drink far too
much green tea I don't know can you
drink too much green tea because I'm
definitely drinking it's got caffeine
you actually can drink too much tea
um there's some like uh there's a few
chemicals in it that are pretty bad if
you drink it like all the time all day
um but like anything that's like that
right if you ate just [__] ham yeah
sure
just lettuce you'd have no nothing else
right everything in moderation generally
yeah oh yeah I'm just like how much tea
is like too much tea you know um I'm
definitely surpassing it I'm pretty sure
um but that's a problem for future me
yeah I feel like I'm in the now you know
I'm I'm trying to worry about that
that's that's that's the video you
should make five years from now being
like the tea didn't kill you sorry about
that you know how it is you should film
it while you're sipping a cup of tea
it's like I bet you're mad yeah that's
that's like that's like a fault in like
human evolution we are so we are so
inadequate in try with like we can
process problems that will happen in our
future but we're so inadequate and
caring about it you know
like yep that's why global warming has
been yeah right I was just about to say
like climate change activism like first
time yeah like hey your body is going to
deteriorate if you don't exercise and
keep healthy every day and you know eat
good and you're like yeah but one more
hamburger right one more Burger
literally every person who smokes
cigarettes is just like yeah I know but
that's that's future me to decide I'm
I'm enjoying it right that it takes so
much energy just to like care about it
and change your life for the better it
just it just yeah some something's wrong
with the brain the creatures of habits
man when we get in a habit we it's hard
for us to kick lately we didn't put
enough points into intelligence
we've programmed our brain to work in
the best way it can and it's got a lot
of flaws yeah yeah right I mean I did
program I'm [__] lazy someone else
did that
I don't know it's weird we're pretty
dumb though that's one thing I do you
think you think you think we are I think
we're pretty [__] dumb we're all some
pretty [__] done dumb Apes just
floating through a rock through space
Apes have a good they stopped at the
right time Evolution wise I think
they're they're chilling oh I have a
great time
well they get to have all the you know
that orangutang or to drive that golf
cart in that one video and he didn't
have to get a license
you know you didn't have to go to the
DMV I think he got the best part of
evolution which is like sit back relax
eat bananas chill out they can get to
drive a golf cart dude I'm just jealous
they get to flick their turds without
any repercussions man like I wish that's
my doctor we should have stopped at dogs
dogs I'm just I I don't think we evolved
we don't we didn't evolve from it
doesn't matter evolutionary world of
dogs
at dogs man the Council of dogs is this
nothing more pure than just a dog I
think a dog
if the world was only dogs would dogs be
friendly to each other I don't think
they would
yeah maybe the reason why dogs ended up
evolving is wholesome and awesome as
they did is because of the filthy human
dogs just agree we tampered and it
worked for once
that was when it was we did a massive W
for once what about cats
they do they they already own the world
let's pull the strings from those
Shadows
can't live in their world yeah what do
you mean it's since the beginning of the
Egyptian age we've worshiped [__]
cats yeah I wonder what it is about cats
that we just we can't help but just
gravitate towards since ancient times
Humanity has not changed they're cute
cats could be like the biggest [__]
[__] in the world and humans are
like I [__] love you and I would die
for you and they are completely right
cats cats are literally the same humans
do that to other humans you're a giant
piece of [__] but I love you like cats
are basically the cigarettes of the
animal wall they're just like I know
this thing is absolutely horrible but
God damn I can't stop I can't stop I I
uh I was at Ludwig's house I got to
stroke uh Coots and that was a very cute
kiss
I thought that sentence
I did get to do that too I was lying
down and then Coots would just jump on
me and he would just want you know a
good cuddling I thought all right yeah
okay I'll allow it I've allowed you to
exist we uh we have this uh we have this
cat in my house in England uh yeah I
remember yeah that's not our cat it's
our neighbor's cats oh okay but it's
really our cat okay it's a Street's cat
we don't know what her name is uh for
some reason Sydney's Sydney uh named her
Scarlett Joe and then that name just
stuck because whenever she shouts it the
cat just comes running so I don't know
what your cat's name is uh sorry uh Mrs
neighbor but uh it's Scarlet Joe now
um and this is appropriators in there
yeah this she she she's too [__]
smart man because she knows okay here's
the thing right we we're we're simple
creatures we just want to give them pets
yeah give them love right they they're
cats we just want to give them pets and
give them love
um Scarlet Joe knows the exact right
amount of pets that she's willing to
give before like saying no no more pets
you're not allowed anymore right and
then and then she knows that we [__]
crave it so like anytime
anytime
anytime we look like we're like you know
a bit more disinterested than usual she
goes
now have a pet and we're like [__] are
you are you giving me a pet and she get
and she just lets us pet her and she
goes all right enough I'm like [__] I
want to pay you more now I want to bet
you more dude she is in full control
[__] I I'm not the the worst thing is I
know she is but I can't stop it okay
okay if she if she wants pets I'm going
to give it to her and God [__] damn
it like it's just I'm telling you man
like two cute animals are just like they
just get the pass she's an evil [__]
being that's that's she's evil man she
she's a manipulative evil [__] being
I believe it and you know what but I
love her
I'm this close to [__] abducting her
from our neighbors man who needs to she
was coming to you yes yeah exactly she
is when when she knows when when uh
when we haven't been uh when we've come
back from like a long trip from like
Japan or something like that the first
day every first day she's always like so
loving so everything we feel loved we
feel like we're back over then every
other day after that she just goes back
to normal all right you've had your time
now I'm just gonna I'm just gonna sit
here and just judge you I don't want to
give you too much sir yeah yeah no no
more serotonin for you sir
oh man what was your cat like when you
grew up because you yeah I had a few
cats
um a few yeah wow yeah we had well when
I was born we had two
um but like my my parents had three the
whole time uh Pocky and little guy
um it was it was weird because it's like
when you have two cats living in the
same house it you really see the
personality differences right right
because like when you just see a cat by
itself it's like okay you know you can
discern maybe some like personality
traits of the cat right the different
cats that you know but like when it's
two cats next to each other it really is
like night and day yeah uh so like I
think like I mean I don't remember a
whole lot because I was really young but
like I remember like little guy was
definitely the [__] in the family
um he would he would do this thing where
like I don't know if you had like memory
problems or whatever but like we would
feed him right and then literally 30
minutes later he'd come back and be like
where the [__] my food
I do that meowing at my dad yeah and my
dad's like [__] I've just fed you leave
me the [__] alone and he just be like no
I'm still hungry give me my [__] food
meanwhile Pokey is like out on The
Veranda just being like
thank you for the meal father that was
absolutely delicious I'm going to saw
some of this stuff bro let me uh you can
pet me now you can come and pay me I'm
full I'm satisfied come here though me
all little guys just being like I'm
still hungry give me my food where is it
and it's just I don't know like I I
loved both cats equally for like
different things but it's just like it
really does just show like how these
animals just have like really just
distinct personalities and it's like and
it's dope you know like you know like
even like when we had we used to have
like a lot of birds as well right like
my parents currently owned like a
cockatiel right now and like compared to
the last cockatiel we had this one is a
million times more of an [__] but
it's like but it's forgivable because
it's cute and the couple of times that
it falls asleep in your hand it's like
you know what all the bite marks you
gave me over the years
I think I've always wondered about birds
why don't they just fly away
what do you mean like what stopping them
just flying away oh I mean our last
cockatiel floor yeah right yeah is there
a point where the bird goes hold on a
second you just fly and never come back
or actually our first our first
cockatiel uh z uh he actually flew away
but then he flew into because you know
we live next to the National Park yeah
he flew out but then got confused to be
like holy [__] where am I because we
could actually see him circling around
like trying to find us and then what he
ended up doing was he just nosedived
into the the the the the forest and so
my dad and I went out to actually go and
find him uh you know hoping that he
didn't fly off somewhere yeah and after
like a 20 minute search we we heard him
we could hear him chirping and I looked
up at this tree and he's just like
perched on top just like looking down
being like [__] help me where
the [__] where am I the [__] have you
been if I saw the bird guy I'd be like
yeah we're not getting that yeah so the
original plan right was like my dad I
took off his jacket and was just like
all right call him down like to know
that we're here and then the moment he
like lands anywhere I'm gonna put the
jacket on top and like wrap him up so he
doesn't like freak out and fly away
somewhere right so that was the original
Appliance of like we're calling him down
he's like looking down being like is it
safe is it safe and he he flies down he
lands on the shoulder but and as soon as
my dad was about to put the jacket on
him I was like no I don't think we
should because this [__] was
gripping onto my shoulders like no
tomorrow it was like it was hurting it's
just like I am not leaving your shoulder
so what ended up happening was it was
like a 20 minute walk back to the house
yeah he just [__] stayed there oh
that's cool he just didn't move he was
just like take me home right now please
so like what what the normal like why do
birds not fly away sometimes like why do
they just um do they ever come back if
they like well I think it depends on
like how the bird was raised so like if
it was raised in captivity its entire
life then it doesn't know the concept of
flying away uh okay right but if if it's
say from like you know you take it from
like the wild then obviously they're
going to be more prone to be like why am
I in this [__] rooms like just fly
away like it's like a dad too and then
just come back like a thing for like
some birds I have no idea how how it is
to own a bird as a pet I think I think
think for some birds yeah I mean it
depends obviously on how long you've
like kept oh it's like dogs as well
right like some dogs run away but then
there are accounts of a couple of days
later the dog just shows up in your
front porch yeah this is like what I
miss you yeah and what did I miss Karen
do this time whereas like some dogs just
run away and you never see them again
right so I think it just depends on like
the attachment factor of the animal yeah
I guess dads do that too
so I guess you know it's not that's how
you need to do the birds of dogs yeah
yeah
you need an AI to stop that yeah I'm
like oh yeah
I know all living creatures do that my
dad
yeah so it was like it was really
fascinating that like you know that like
even with because you know I never had
that concept of like birds having that
idea right because I was kind of the
same as you when I first started owning
a bird of like oh we have to be careful
where every time because they might just
[__] fly away just like Scout every
[__] like crevice
but then you know there are some places
where like uh you know you could like
interact with like an owl or like an
eagle or like a bigger Bird yeah and
they're not attached to anything but
they're just like chilling out and
they're just like they could fly away at
any time but they're just like nope you
know what um I like it here I think I'm
gonna stay here yeah yeah so it's
interesting I've I've never I've never
owned a bird before uh but I have seen
one grow up before this is this is just
a really weird story uh that this talk
has just reminded me of so when I was
living in Thailand uh my house in
Thailand is like over
is uh over like a pond and I kind of
think uh we have we have a pawn next to
our
Big Spender
I mean it's perfect
it's Thailand okay we know we live we
live on like the outskirts of Bangkok so
it's like a bit more in nature
um and near like uh near the rooftop and
everything like that or just on the
balcony Birds would like like to make
nests and everything like that uh and so
in my office uh in Thailand I sit right
next to a window that has a really
really good view of the places uh of the
place where Birds would love to make
their nests and everything like that and
so one bird made a nest that was kind of
like right right next to my window uh
almost next to my window right
um so I I saw basically that a bird had
made a nest and like I saw that you know
she had laid some eggs and some beef and
some mice uh birds like some baby birds
have had had hatched and every day I
would come down and I would see the mum
feeding them and slowly and slowly I
would see them like you know grow up and
I will never forget this point because I
I would I would see them every single
day I saw these little chicks grow up
and everything like that
um and there's a day where I saw their
first flight all right well I saw that
first flight and it was it was
interesting for me because I've never
seen how birds just learned to fly yeah
right uh initially I just thought okay
Instinct they just know how to fly
um nope they uh that that doesn't happen
actually yeah and well at least that's
not what I saw
um so actually the mother helps to teach
them how to fly right so what happens is
uh he's here's me like I'm sitting I'm
sitting on my window there's the nesters
over there and what happens is the
mother flies to like the little it flies
my window and it like chirps at the
Chiclets it's like come on come here
yeah I'm gonna teach you how to fly come
on come on come on you can do it you can
do it
um and initially uh and initially the
chick's like all right I can do this
immediately does it right
and then but then I think something just
clicked and in his brain to be like oh
that was scary actually that was I was
in the air and mind you between my
window and where the nest was was just
pawned it was just water right so if
they fall they're [__] drowning yeah
right and so the mother flies back to
the nest
and and she she continues chirping for
the chicklet to fly back to the nest
doesn't do it
one minute I'm not doing that one minute
passes doesn't do it Mom flies back
flies through the nest again
chirps again
three minute passes doesn't do it the
chicklet looks at his mum and
and then after the mum chirped really
loudly this one time chicklet just
stands on the edge looks at his looks at
his mum
shits himself
I'm not joking get it confident I'm not
joking I'm looking at this bird his
mum's like chirping he shoots himself
and then he takes off and it's a low
takeoff and at this point I'm I'm
invested in this book because I'm
thinking to myself if this bird falls in
yeah I'm running out of my office and
I'm diving into this Pawn to save this
bird yeah I see this bird growing up
this bird ain't dying on his first
flight and what happens is he takes off
but he's too low he's like flapping his
wings yeah and he
what happens is the nest is purged up
there he hits uh he hits the little
balcony before the nest yeah he like
panicly like like tries to grab on tries
to grab on flaps his wing I was like
halfway through running out but luckily
he just got enough elevation to get his
foot on the nest and I was like oh my
[__] God I'm so [__] proud of you
man that's it
I'm so proud of him that's cute that's a
cute Story how to clean the bird [__]
off my balcony so you know you know that
was it was it was worth it yeah shits
himself proceeds to fly
I just [__] the fear out of myself
[Laughter]
in that moment I realized us and birds
were not so different When We Fear [__]
When We Fear stuff we want to [__]
ourselves oh yeah not just Birds just do
it just commit you know they don't care
they just [__] themselves we say I'm
shooting myself the bird actually shits
itself
absolutely hey speaking of wholesome
though look at all these lovely patrons
yeah they're awesome so a wholesome as
hell because they're supporting us yes
do you own a cat do you own a dog tell
us how awesome they are or tell us how
Sonic storage down yeah give us some
wholesome pet stories if you have any
we'd love to hear it but uh hey if you'd
like to support the show then make sure
to go to our patreon patreon.com
trashtaste also follow us on Twitter
send us memes on the subreddit and if
you hate her face listen to us on
Spotify and uh what a wholesome episode
also it wasn't a wholesome
this wasn't another weird trash days
episode also if you're in Hawaii doing
the alert and you confessed uh and you
confess to your crush please tell us the
story yeah any confession any any
confession yeah I'm genuinely curious
what the outcome of that was yeah but
that has been this week of trash taste
we'll see you all next time bye
[Music]
foreign